sure this is this is recording yep this
is good we're good over there
and we'll of course of course send it
everything to you in a few days to
confirm
if you can just move a little bit to
your right i'm i may because my face is
in the top right
that's perfect you can even go a little
bit back to the left this is great yeah
just dead center is
dead center is perfect all right and and
how did i just pronounce your full name
just make sure i'm making a mistake
donna griffith all right i think we can
get started
donna griffith thank you so much for
joining me how are you
well we're gonna we're going to talk
soon about how actually during
uh during covet you accelerated your
business to over 150
growth but but we're going to leave that
to to to the later half of the
conversation because i'd like to start
off with with your journey donna
you're you're a worldwide known
storyteller you've helped
thousands of entrepreneurs founders uh
ceos executives
work through their stories and the way
that you are saying it is to turn raw
data into something meaningful and
magical
that that others buy into and engage
with uh it's
it's it's you know it's never been more
relevant than today
and i think that if as as i'm watching
the world unfold especially in terms of
politics and entrepreneurship
it's all about storytelling and it's all
about framing but
let's go from the beginning donna who
are you
i love that polisher over diamonds
why is it so hard it's telling a story
you start off with the beginning then
you have a middle and an end you put a
conflict in the middle and then you
finish with a
with a hollywood happy ending
so
right
wow
and obviously when you're when you're
meeting these different founders and
executives you're meeting them across
all different stages of their life cycle
right from very early stage to very late
stage
and i'm sure that the messaging is also
different in how they convey some of
them is more data driven some of that is
more
you know dreamlike and and let's go on a
journey of what the future could hold
for
for the world right
right
sure
100 so donna you start off your life
orthodox
at 16 you know what you're going to be
doing with your life
walk me back to your childhood i have to
understand how does one become
an expert storyteller to the point where
they're working with thousands of
entrepreneurs and executives
yep
drama therapy
what's what's drama therapy
wrong
so
all right
craigslist wow
wow
unbelievable just unbelievable so going
back to startup stories
walk me through what a meeting with you
would be like so if i'm coming in
and i'm saying donna i have a i have
this big thing that i have to have to
raise capital i have to go give
a keynote about my comp my product i
have a sales pitch to this crazy company
what what is our engagement look like
what does it mean to work with a
storyteller
right
two hours so you know people people work
for
weeks on slide decks and presentations
iterating getting feedback from
from from so many different people these
are you know sometimes these are the
make or break moments for the company
right if i'm taking my my sliding and i
have an opportunity to pitch in front of
a top tier vc this is pretty much my
moment of glory right not just for the
starter but also as me as a founder
this is a chance to to position
ourselves
how do you get this done in two hours
because you're not necessarily an expert
in their field you don't necessarily
know these people personally
right
that makes sense
and what is the feedback loop so you
send them off they take the slide deck
do they do they come back update how
right right right
sure
wow
sure 100
so
of course of course but so you've got to
you've got to see over the past
over the past years the the industry of
storytelling and this is a very unique
perspective i think because as an
entrepreneur
or as an executive you really get to see
one story
unfold over and over in front of in
front of different people over a life
cycle you get to see thousands of
different stories
unfold at different stages across across
the years
what has the industry changed at all are
the expectations different
about storytelling from let's say 10
years ago
right
yep
100 percent
right
so kovit hits uh you mentioned that you
look back in 2008 every session that you
went through
and now uh you've managed to
make some changes in order to accelerate
your business and time when
you don't even get to meet face to face
with those that you're helping tell
their story and to me it sounds so
it there's there's so much humanity and
and and so much
personality and storytelling and you're
and i'm and i'm sure that when you're
sitting in a room with somebody
you this energy and this chemistry it's
part of the process right of
understanding each other
and yet you managed to to to even
accelerate your business tell me about
that
ah
really
wow
right
amazing
yep
right people nibbled
amazing donna uh i have to say
i mean it it's it's amazing to me how uh
you know
people work so hard on such amazing
technologies for so long
and it sometimes it boils down to a few
minutes it boils down to a two-minute
pitch or a five-minute pitch or even an
hour pitch and and and you're
trying to sum up a work of years in a
10-minute presentation and at the end
you know it's it's almost i think a
night an analogy to
people go to the gym three times the
three times a week four times a week to
work on their body so much
they people don't really put too much
effort most of the time on their minds
and and training their minds whether it
be better sleep quality better food
psychology whatever and i think that
there's a similar thing here and i think
that the work that you're doing is just
so incredible and i can't wait to work
with you
as well when i have my own startup and
my own projects but before we leave then
i want to thank you for being
i want to thank you for being so
generous with your time i need three
words that you would use to describe
yourself
getting done
i love it
yep
i love that
i love that donna
thank you very very much this is just
wonderful
bye bye a really really wonderful thank
you i'll send it to you as soon as we
have it this was just
this is just phenomenal and so i'm
stopping the recording now
on the zencaster it'll take it if about
a minute or two to upload so just don't
close the zencaster yet
and you'll see on the website that it's
uploading so it might take it
a couple minutes you'll see that now
it's at
three percent but it's not recording
anymore so you can just
leave it open a little bit wonderful and
i'll send it to you as soon as we have
it
i think within a couple days
well i'm so i'm leaving the i'm in
california and i'm going back to israel
my girlfriend just got clearance to come
to israel
through a program so i'm going to greece
for two weeks for a quarantine
and then from greece to israel
yeah i'm going with going with my dog
just in the house on the on the ocean
and uh
so it's in next so it's six hours north
of
of athens next to thessaloniki there's a
little bay
and there's a very it's a nice village
where there's like
like houses on right on the beach so
it's like
very secluded so thessaloniki is the
airport that you fly into and then about
an hour away there's a bay
with a with a village of just houses
like each house is 100 meters away from
the other
very secluded perfect for quarantine
yep
amazing
wow
it's my it's just a beautiful place
beautiful place
wonderful donna i'll send it to you in a
few days thank you again for doing this
bye bye thank you
bye
you